hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to a bless to God okay
all right a little her they called them
heritage yeah okay they called lid
mother okay not just a cop
uh-huh to cite Christians
something else yeah okay I was just
about to catch all them up to exactly
what you just said so can you let me do
my job and then you do whatever the hell
you're about to walk into I don't know
I've I want to go there
hi you can hide by crouching underwater
do I need to oh I do oh I forget how to
crab blue good thing my camera's
waterproof Pete oh he's looking at me
okay that's not good hi hi friend
what are you looking for are you looking
for a heretic or argue a heretic
I imagine that we must be in the center
of the cult village if we're so close to
where we need to be for that search and
find Lin missing that I can't stay down
here indefinitely so I'm gonna pop back
up and then I'm gonna be and on my way
over there all right
again don't really know how I'm keeping
this dry but I think I see you yeah I
just jump for joy in front of every
window you see then that's damn it okay
so we need to find more batteries more
everything we need to find Lin we need
to get the heck out of here oh yeah real
subtle with that window there are you
doing it except jumping for joy oh boy
Oh
okay so I can make it if he doesn't
sweep over to the left then I can make
it I'm gonna go go go go I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go I would go and go no screws
loose down
seems like I'm fine oh I'm not fine
all right I'm fine
underwater good thing I was a Olympic
level swimmer when I was a kid able to
hold my breath for 10 minutes at times
yeah okay all right then
the learning of our children that's
[ __ ] talking about okay finally jeez
go away you goof you're freaking I don't
know what I did but I sidestep somewhere
open this holy hey that's right oh god
I'm trapped in my memories okay good I
start this thing
oh I've a grec elections about this oh
yeah what the hell you're here mine why
not both porque no los go Lori I have to
do this you should have loved me you
should he'll help - hi Jesus forgive me
I don't know what to do I'm so so sorry
oh okay a member
yeah why am i able to record this what
in the world is that bright shining
light what does it do to the people in
this town what kind of influence does it
have over the people here that's so
weird I don't
waistband oh good okay what is it
and oh you were highschool sweetheart we
from the very beginning good
does that mean yeah well that's me
fourth grade uh-huh Karen thoughts
continue yeah what's up with her i huh
what's up with oh is that is that my
wife cut what you have such a
shit-eating grin here all right okay put
it down I don't need to record that I'm
already handsome enough as it is he's
got a tuba where's the troll there's the
Trump pets that's what I know how to
play hello Kijang okay ah the old
familiar class always wails of the
Damned and all okay so I'm gonna pop out
of me huh principal my education it's so
it oh [ __ ] I'm not supposed to actually
look at you am i who are you who are you
that's even worse
all right you know what I got a few
questions for you sir wow you just Oh
bad
[Music]
all right then I didn't think you were a
threat at all oh hey how's it going door
okay what's this about responsibility I
have none of that can you teach me how
to do that respect I don't have none of
that for nobody expecially me and myself
kindness but [ __ ] eNOS tolerance
okay all right this is getting a little
self-esteem nope self-discipline huh
confidence no all right hello Oh for
some reason I did not expect that to
actually open oh and it's a snowy day
night this is what this is what people
call night usually I'm a sticky for day
oh hello
so what am i doing out here I can't do
okay all right then
hello where am I supposed to go
I guess follow this trail oh right then
why am I actually here whoa
okay thank you wind I guess oh my lumbar
oh yeah I bruised my coccyx
that's your flat bone you think my
classes is hey hi you're a major yes are
you know not a lot of things and things
okay
no no yeah well they'll do it if they
find you out here come on okay I'm gonna
go with what idea that I don't trust
anybody
but I mean are you one of them and with
spider you want
I ain't not trying to kill you yeah yeah
does that mean I'm gone see too much to
keep the faith you but you're not one of
those other ones the heretics a squat
with my wife got Scogin that he cast out
he didn't complain when not pressed
himself my aunt early and she not like
the deed I'm sorry
he said my grandson ladyship would nurse
was my thing any craft neither billion
mm well that's a weird thing to have in
existence and at all in reality and why
I mean weird isn't even the right word
for that ever chance to run from them
idiot some stories I would give to the
top my whole life
the problem noticed oh yeah real
eloquent on your daughter she was eight
months pregnant
blonde hair cut like a boy's yeah what
do you know you seen her it's why we
came here
it's you all right tell me so good oh
well yeah we're gonna lie don't lie Oh
God god bless you
yeah okay yeah you maybe should be
littles retire all right you should be a
little suspicious to me because I don't
think that's actually true I'm a liar
Wow
okay okay yeah that seems good I don't
trust you and I just lied to you what
would it matter if I told him that his
daughter was dead
well that ain't no good at all all right
you know right he selects here I'll keep
you see oh thanks to her and he'll he
was gonna treat you right
oh he's gonna treat me right don't tell
me your last names Bradbury oh boy
okay I'm sure you're not gonna get some
inconspicuous visitors at any moment
here yeah I'm sure that's gonna be just
fine I'm gonna rest up don't worry about
Lynn or nothing Oh sleep yeah my wife is
pregnant and lost I'm gonna take a nap
here I go then I'm taking a [ __ ] nap I
guess I mean I might be going crazy
maybe all this isn't real to begin with
I mean I don't even know where I am I
went onto this quote-unquote
reservation and reservation for what at
this point because it obviously isn't
for its original purpose so who are
these people and how did a cult form out
in these woods
and who's Jessica was Jessica Jessica
sounds like someone that might have
killed herself when they were kids or
maybe not maybe not killed us off in
Hatta number maybe was killed
I get that voice if there's actual ad
was gospel I'm going a hundred tests I
knew where the outside were scrappy
you'll need your help finding the devil
told her about me not questions even now
other Chapel oh [ __ ] you Ron even you
treated me right oh boy
problems your daughter you can top it
off yeah maybe we don't their job would
be God him oh let me talk about I could
find
ah
oh oh okay all right
I feel like maybe and I should stop
being a little bit of a coward here and
how you are not a friendly person you
are not a happy Giver you're not a smile
deliverer Oh No
yeah you didn't think for you to think
songs that maybe I could have been a bit
um of a more of assistance for that you
gonna still be alive maybe oh boy good
for me
oh yeah what a good guy thank you yeah I
didn't do you any good
I guess he died with the happy idea that
his daughter might be alive like I
didn't want to go down here well there's
only bad memories okay I guess I'll take
everything that I can hear my head is
wounded isn't baby still in working
condition oh sorry Ethan I liked you
when you were alive but alas things did
not go the way they should have gone so
I will carry on with your legacy inside
my heart and hope for better days round
the corner
oh that a flashlight I could probably
use that well maybe not
I don't even know what arrow we're in I
mean it must be some sort of modern era
for me to avid
camera like this but these people seem
to be in slightly backward styles swing
is exhausting fine safe ground to
recover okay oh hello hi how are you
doing what are you doing what I'm sorry
what what are you doing in the water
displaces braking forces yeah
it's children of hell okay okay you know
and I'm gonna find safe ground while you
do that whatever you're doing over there
come on kids get up bills oh well I I
again I don't know what that means but
it does that mean the heretics are gonna
be doing things hello how are you okay
are you doing it ah I look good I mean
you look better probably but maybe not
I'm the only time I've seen you like I
visit this lady and see what the hell
she's up there hey lady you want to give
me some help you want to read me some
Bible verses hide hide the barrel you
douche he's full oh god oh god no it's a
scarecrow
alright well see seems to be gone can't
carry any more bandages
good cuz I don't think I need them what
do we got Chapter five yeah you hold
your [ __ ] fault they're about to read
and I looked in a gyre on wound from the
night of five turned inward burning from
all directions towards the center and
through the line from the walls of my
room so that I hung in a void that's
shown in rainbows like oiled on black
mirror God they loved run-on sentences
and I looked despite the pain and behold
out of the midst of the inward fire came
the likeness of a creature a figure as
like to a man as a circle is who sphere
as a cross-section of the sphere would
make a circle so the cross-section of
this creature would make a man and this
was their appearance they had the
appearance of Jesus Christ agony upon
the cross and in chest and sex had the
appearance of a man and their faces were
innumerable and joined to one another a
thousand eyes and everywhere I little
sorry spoke in tongues for a second
there the thousand eyes and everything a
mouth with wings and jaws inseparable
even inciting the purpose of the eyes
and the purpose of the jaws was both for
a more perfect consumption thoughts were
their faces and in the next moment they
were the bones of the four horses of the
Apocalypse and the poems of the horsemen
too and in the moment that they followed
the phases and sex organs of angels and
in the moment that have followed a
bonfire of flame with voices singing and
beauty to run the mind and in the moment
that followed a reflection in slivered
glass for their faces were all of these
things at once and the wings would join
to one another as they flap to move to
rest I'm and I could not take air into
my body I'm trying to channel the the
not guy his kind of voice and delivery
there I'll get it over time gotta get
that Southern drawl in there Oh [ __ ]
crows oh hi how good but your [ __ ]
crows you think you know things you know
nothing oh boy oh hi hello hi hello hi
hello
how's it going what are you doing what
are you doing over there I didn't want
to know about that okay oh no I lost it
oh no I lost it oh oh hello hello I'm
gonna get you I got the thickest zooms
this side of the Mississippi
well I was gonna have the sickest room
the side of the Mississippi but
apparently not okay so what do I do
about this I can't exactly get out over
there oh that's the opposite of good
Oh No here yes yes nice slide in the
third base there okay uh okay gotta hide
I think they were on to me for a second
there but if I hide maybe I'll be able
to get away from them
because I remember I didn't do this do
well in the demo and I'm not going to
make the same mistakes that I did this
time around I'm going to survive and not
get my jungle region removed via pickaxe
that would be less than ideal you sons
of [ __ ] you better find me a way out
of here
this way out of here better be the way
out of here I think this is if I
remember correctly yes yes yes yes yes
okay okay I don't think anyone's noticed
me just yet
Oh can't think I'm okay I'm not okay I'm
not okay
oh hi okay all right then Oh are you
doing I'm not a not a heretic or nothing
apparently I just birthed the anti-crime
okay all right then
calm down there sunny Jim all right what
do we got here
interact all right let's open this up
I'm sure there's gonna be quiet happy
now notice me I've been sprinting
through their camp screaming at the top
of my lungs they should have drawn
somebody's a dog save don't know hi
angel of god oh god oh god oh god oh god
why'd you do that to me you did you dick
oh my god why'd you do that to me
none of a [ __ ] I didn't even do enough
oh you that's a [ __ ] okay where do I go
from here it seems like it might have
been a dead end
oh wait it is over here hello alright
well I'll go up this way then school oh
yeah oh I'm getting a lot of memories
about this eyelash sure does love it
squeeze moments whew hi how you doing
there buddy
whoo this was fun I'm a pullet oh hi oh
I'm still pulling I don't know why hello
you look like someone from the evil
within is there evil within you alright
I guess you're dead you don't care
right then I'm gonna go this way then
lalalala damn it yeah booty back hold
that Oh God well forgets my infected
wound Oh gross
why why is it because it might be a
horse of the apocalypse about what it
might be
jeez trying to remember what all the
colorful language in that last chapter
was it was trying to paint the depiction
of the all this recession it's trying to
paint the depiction of what this guy was
seeing as beings of a higher dimension
what he was going with the sphere and
circle reference soul of Christ make me
already fallen off guide my salvation
blood of Christ let me drink your wine
either by the severed I gave me vision
angels God let me your sworn King Jesus
hear my prayer Hylian your own you keep
me close to you defend me from the
wicked world and ready me for the
devil's hour in the Fellowship of temple
gate then I might defend your creation
until you give me rest a man ok maybe
that's a secret message
sips bubble octazooka Dom but uh yes I
knew it
ok goodbye go this blows hide in a
barrel of blood really I don't want to
do dance you know how I usually have
good ideas I'm gonna put that in the bad
idea category hello oh why who did that
look at that what was that
hello oh I hit a cactus oh ok yeah this
is OK alright
why oh no no no [ __ ] was that it killed
all the birds what the [ __ ] the poor
birds
oh I mean all the other dead bodies I've
seen thus far yeah okay but the birdy
oh alright then
well that's sad okay do I go down there
do I go through here
oh don't seem like good options but I'm
gonna go here first okay hello I pick
that up please thank you there we go
alright this looks rickety well I guess
I can't go this way anyway she's got to
be maybe through the mine the horrible
horrible mines filled with death ah how
about that oh god I thought it actually
was going to be mines missing there Oh
birdy Oh
Oh that battery down there okay I'll
take that
she's um uh what happened to this guy
why did the Ethan have to die the moment
that he tried to help me how it always
goes in these video games oh this is a
narrow ledge no one bombed me no one
spooked me with any other worldly
influence please I'm dragging you all
right fine the good morning uh-oh Badu
he crumbled legs in what world would
that benefit me why would I need to peek
from a goddamn ledge okay I guess I'm
going oh my god well that appear down to
nowhere oh the world's worst slip and
slide here we go down down into the
depths god damn it we are going into
mines aren't we
my gamer sense tingled too hard and I
was right about this wood they didn't
okay oh boy Oh what is that what is that
what is that what are you freakin weirdo
Church why am no I'm kind of yeah Harry
temple oh you're an expert on this all
of a sudden are you plate well good for
you
Jessica give you an insight on that one
able order that well I think there's
some cannibalism going on here
always good when there's cannibalism oh
I made that jump
are you [ __ ] me right now you're
freaking frack old dry that's good okay
there you barely maybe you barely made
it there you trying to dick me over and
you barely made it we gotta get back to
the village he uses bandage you don't
need to use the bandage right now I feel
bad
maybe I need it for my emotional wounds
did you ever think about that game I
don't think they did right away we how
do i what the [ __ ]
alrighty then Oh lovely
I like the decorations you've done with
the place
it's adorable in fact hey if the piano
man could stop playing his instrument
over there I guarantee that's not very
good for it or me in general or anything
for that matter
Lynn Lynn Lynn Lynn
[Music]
all right yeah that's always good Oh
[ __ ] goddamn it with this motion where
am I uh the chapel somebody there will
know where they've taken me why would
someone there know that why didn't you
just go to the heretic place you were at
the heretic place what that wasn't the
main heretic like okay oh who the hell
are you oh no oh no oh no no it's a
travel [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I thought that was
a challenge it Amelie thought that was a
trap I thought I was gonna die I got
flashbacks from Resident Evil well as
playing Ethan must die oh my god oh boy
okay so something happened there but I
can't get through this way it looks like
there's nothing good for me here anyway
I'm kind of puzzle here oh I could just
crawl through okay never mind I can just
crawl through great good oh boy still
the decorations March 9 more children
bed not says there's no sin in such
infanticide as all our soldiers in God's
army martyrs fallen on the field and
define to the Archfiend all those babies
with slit throats and charred flesh will
be waiting immaculate for us in paradise
Baba Natha also says that our sins find
us in our dreams our sins find us in
their dreams my dreams are nothing but
the murder of my children and I wake
laughing and around
and often wetness tsaldari love the room
look I was this morning thinking I was
wedded with the blood of my child
slit throat but it was wetness of my own
making the others of similar guitars
whether we make beans eaters we gather
and share our visions and wonder at
their meaning
I feel increasingly this is a message
but nothing holy ok alright then so this
is a heretic abode ah lovely of course
much like everything else the heretics
that made here alrighty then good for
you and your colorful language let's see
what's going on all right
hello oh I shout into the dough you
alive
oh [ __ ] didn't mean to do that you alive
are you I don't particularly trust you
well ok I'll take your word for it that
poppin off oh what a handsome fella that
guy is he's a great leader in this Oh
quiet distance
oh why dad whatever that is then what's
up
God himself killed it all time nailed
him to a tree and I'll covering today my
dad and when his old okay that doesn't
mean anything word alright then
Sullivan Papa Zico liar charlatan temple
to gout addicts coward rapist child
killer I am gone and I have taken with
me all with the courage to see the truth
come after us hunt us down we're waiting
and eager to murder and [ __ ] everybody
you send up the mountain I don't hate
you good Jesus hate the Baptist for
being a Jew I could not have found my
true vision without your years of
ignorance and [ __ ]
I can never have had the courage to seek
the truth if not fueled by my anger at
your lies your God is a child
superstition your faith is an
embarrassment the signs of the true
father were before you before us all and
you vainglorious gullible too stupid to
draw breath you thought the visions were
punishment from an angry an ominous God
your God is afraid because your God is
no God at all your God is your own ego
vulnerable and false an embarrassment my
god is no God at all but he is true and
he is here in every moment of ecstasy
and his child will [ __ ] care this
world or everlasting glory I do not ask
that you join us I tell you you will
join us because our love is greater than
you ever imagined
if there's one thing to describe out
this letter it's lava and a lot of it so
anyway I guess I'll end on the lovely
note so thank you everybody so much for
watching I'm going to carry on with this
very soon I'm going to be doing a lot
about less too and it is so much fun and
I love it so thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next week bye-bye
[Music]